hey youtubers is charlie so the flash
and arrow just confirmed the dates that
they're coming back this fall it is
pretty much the exact same time they
came back last year the flash season two
starts Tuesday october six arrow season
four starts that next day wednesday
october seventh both of them will have
23 episodes they'll do like the first
nine then go on winter break then come
back in january since they're premiering
at the same time i'm expecting them to
come back in january at the same time
it's like the third week in january
which would be January nineteenth for
the flash this year and the 20th for
arrow legends of tomorrow though and
everyone's still confused about when
that starts episode one will probably
debut the same week flash and arrow come
back in January they haven't said which
night that's going to air on yet but I'm
expecting you to air on a different
night from flash and arrow which would
make it monday thursday or friday
they're filming legends of tomorrow
right now so they'll probably have some
news at comic-con they'll probably
release some more information about
what's going on with that they just
hired their showrunner his name's Phil
Klemmer he was the showrunner on the
Tomorrow People you know another Greg
Berlanti show he worked on Veronica Mars
he worked on Chuck so he's worked with a
lot of these actors before and the
producers they did say this year flash
and arrow will tee up the plot of
legends of tomorrow so they might use
the mid-season finale of both shows to t
that up or they could use the episode 8
flare o story they're doing the same
thing they did last year where there's
like a shared villain between arrow and
the flash that starts on flash and moves
to arrow that's not the only crossover
though like all the shows all three
shows will cross over with each other
it's just that the flare o crossover
involves most of the main cast jumping
from show to show the thing they did
last year with the mid-season finale is
though is that after they did that flare
Oh episode each show had its own
independent story for the mid-season
finale the flash is all about revealing
Harrison wells is the reverse-flash in
the arrow episode was all about killing
Oliver they might do the same thing or
they might mix some allege ins of
tomorrow stuff in there I'm slowly
starting to get ready for comic-con I'm
not expecting them to show off a lot of
new footage just because they don't
start shooting flash and they don't
start shooting arrow till the Monday
after Comic Con it's kind of a bummer
but Marc Guggenheim said that they're
not going to bring an arrow season 4
trailer so I'm assuming they're not
going to bring a flash season 2 trailer
they're not going to come empty-handed
though comic-con this year is huge for
TV and for
Warner Brothers in general Marvel Sony
and paramount aren't taking any of their
film stuff so obviously Warner Brothers
definitely stepping up there Batman vs
Superman presents the price off the new
trailer but Warner Brothers TV is a huge
deal like last year they did the big
super panel the probably gonna do that
again they have Supergirl to promote
this is really like dese easier so
there's going to be a whole bunch of
stuff they're not going to come
empty-handed if anything they might
bring the blooper reels from flash and
arrow there was actually this weird
thing somebody some random person posted
the arrow season 3 blooper reel to
YouTube this morning it's since been
taken down it's been torpedoed by Warner
Brothers lawyers but I have no idea how
they get their hands on it because the
DVD is a gnat till sep tember what's
probably gonna happen at comic-con is
that just each of the shows will just
talk about some of the new characters
they have coming in some of the new plot
lines we already know about like the
patty spivot type character that the
flash is casting they might have some
more characters than ready to announce
we know about mirror master we know
about dr. alchemy I'm sure everybody's
gonna be asking danielle Panabaker and
the producers about killer frost stuff
so there'll be tons of flash stuff to
talk about as for arrow we know all
about Damien dark they just announced a
new African American character that's
supposed to be like a tech type person
that will interact a lot with Felicity
Marc Guggenheim did say that they were
gonna follow up on the Felicity CEO
thing in a big way if you remember at
the end of season 4 she signed the
papers that essentially gave her control
of Palmer Tech she wrote off with Oliver
into the sunset so it seemed like they
dropped that storyline but mark
Guggenheim's like nope that's gonna be a
big deal in season 4 I think the biggest
question I'm expecting people to ask
Stephen Amell though is will he be green
arrow by the end of the season because
he said the arrow identity is completely
dead he's not going to be calling
himself the arrow anymore so even if
they don't have trailers to show off I
mean there's this still gonna be like a
ton of stuff and yes they are doing like
the big super TV panel where they have
like all the DC TV shows together at the
same time but arrow and the flash will
do their separate comic-con panels too
they haven't announced who they're
bringing it'll probably most of the main
cast or Ernie the actors that aren't
busy filming other stuff at the moment
John Barrowman said that he literally
just signed his arrow season for
contract I guess he has to sign a new
contract once a year but it just
confirms we'll be seeing a lot of Merlin
ratio goal I think that was part of my
predictions for season 4
how ridiculous would it have been if he
had not resigned and come back for
Season 4 like they would have just
dropped that storyline I haven't really
done any big comic con preview videos
yet but what's gonna happen is is when
we get a little bit closer and they
announced the final schedule I'll say
like which panels I'm going to be
recording I mean obviously I'll do like
the flash and arrow but they'll be
videos on top of those panel videos like
if they release trailers anything like
that I know I've been doing the weekly
Marvel DC giveaway but when we actually
do get to like like that week of
comic-con I'll do special merge
giveaways because they'll have tons of
cool comic con toys what I'm gonna try
and do is wednesday night on preview
night i'm gonna try and buy like as much
stuff as possible that's when I blow up
my money here's my big question for you
guys you know given all the stuff
they've announced about legends of
tomorrow arrow in the flash what are you
most excited about inside the arrow
verse for this next year the two words
on the tip of my tongue right now are
Vandal Savage I'm so excited to see how
they weave legends of tomorrow into
these other two shows it's meant to be a
show all by itself like it'll have its
own storyline but they're using it is
like this platform to weave this larger
comic book universe if you haven't read
convergence or you haven't been reading
secret wars on the on the Marvel side of
things they have like this big comic
book event once a year and that all
these lesser titles that we've in with
it that's what they're doing with the
arrow verse right now so the Secret Wars
of the arrow verse is legends of
tomorrow convergence would probably be a
better comparison but I'm a bigger fan
of secret wars right now than I am of
convergence originally I'd intended to
do a video on killer frost that was
going to be like my next flash video but
I wanted to talk about the Premier's
just just because they literally just
announced that this morning so my next
flash video will be killer frost be sure
to subscribe to get it and all you have
to do to enter like the DC Marvel
giveaways is just you know be a
subscriber and leave a comment whenever
I post Marvel and DC videos that that's
really simple we have to mention Arkham
Knight too though I just got my ps4
arkham bundles so I'll probably doing
gameplay videos in the next couple days
the pc version is supposed to suck
something fierce so i would advise going
with a console version what I'll do with
those videos is I'll pry post the first
one on this channel just so i know
everybody finds it and then i'll post
all the other gameplay videos on my
charlie streams bonus channel there's a
link for that in the description maybe
some streaming the
weekend on my twitch channel to that
there's also a link for that in the
description so there's like a whole
bunch of stuff happening right now
hopefully you guys aren't having panic
attacks from all the excitement but in
case you didn't see the news yesterday
new spider-man announced you can click
here for my video for my reaction to
that and you can click here to learn all
about the multiverse and the flash
season 2 thank you so much watching
everybody let's high five I'll see you
guys tonight